حد اقصى سعر النفط الروسيه المنقول بحرا
وضعته مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا لمنع روسيا من الاستفاده من
حربها العدوانيه على اوكرانيا كما تقول
وجعلت السقف عند 60 دولارا للبرميل ويعني
ذلك التزاما بعدم تجاوزه في عقود الشراء
ومطالبه كل السفن الحامله لنفط الروسي
بتوفير اثباتات عن منشا النفطي وسعر
الشراء ولن تتمكن شركه التامين والشحن
والوساطه والتمويل ونحو 90% يقع في
الاتحاد الاوروبي او في المملكه المتحده
من التعامل مع الخميسي الا اذا تم تسعيره
بالسقف الاقصى او اقل منه الاتفاق تم بعد
ان كان الدول مثل بولندا والتونيا
واسبانيا تطالب بسقف سعري اقل من 30
دولارا وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جنتيل
قالت ان سقف السعر سيضيق الخناقه بشكل
اكبر على اراده بوتين وسيمكن دول
المستورده من الحصول على الخصومه الاكبر
ورات رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه في القرار
مساهمه في استقرار اسواق الطاقه العالميه
بل وسيفيد حسبها بشكل مباشر الاقتصاديه
الناشئه والدول الناميه تلك مبررات الدول
الغربيه لكن تم معطيات اخرى فاكبر مستهلك
النفط الخمر روسي وهما الصين والهند
مستفيده ثانيه من خصومه موسكو على
مسترياتهما بل ان الصادرات مسك نفسيه
منقوله بحرا زادت الى القاره الاسيويه
بمقدار الثلث على اساس سنوي في الاشهر
الماضيه من العام الحالي روسيا بدورها
المسؤوله عن تلبيه قرابه عشره ونصف من
الطلب العالمي على النفط الخام صرحت
علانيه انها لن تقف مكتوفه اليدين واحد
خياراتها ببساطه سيكون حضره تصدير الخمرسي
لمن يحاول فرض السقف للاسعار مما قد يشعل
الاسواق باسعار مرتفعه قد يلتقي ذلك مع ما
قاله قبل اسابيع رئيس التنفيذي لشركه تطلع
من ان وضع السقف لسعر الروسي قد يحلق
بالعكس بالاسعار عاليا
وما يوضح مقاربه موسكو ما قاله وزير
خارجيتها سر لافروف من ان الاهم ليس سقف
السعر المقترح بل التفاوض المباشر مع
الشركاء لا يمكن الجسم بمدفاعيه هذا السقف
ومدى تاثيره في الاقتصاد الروسي وافقا
محررين بسبب معوقات محتمله في الشحن لكن
النطاق السعريه المعلنه اعلى بكثير من
تكلفه انتاج النفط في روسيا وبين مبررات
غربيه وردود روسيه حاله عدم يقين تظل
التلازم سوق الطاقه العالميه وحديث متكرر
عن قواعد التجاره العالميه ودعوات
الابتعاد عن السيسي تجاره النفط والغاز